looking at your bio i know that you have
a passion for bringing a voice to people
that are you know physically or mentally
challenged so in what sense were you
bringing a voice to linda's story who
was also marginalized in her own way
she's a single mother facing addiction
well i think everybody in this is a
victim i think linda's a victim i think
the girls are victims i think the little
boy is a victim and i think there's a
lot of guilt to go around for how the
girls ended up in this situation and i
wanted to see if i could make the story
uh sympathetic and not just sort of what
you read in the headlines not okay well
this this woman was a bad mom and so
these bad girls did this bad thing uh i
wanted to see if i could make it much
more compelling than so make everyone
have a reason for their life having
reason for their choices and hopefully
understand them if not sympathize with
them
you